Y
INDEPENDENCE, HOW ABOUT AMERICAN
ENERGY DOMINANCE.
AND SO MUCH MORE.
HE IS A HOST OF UNFILTERED
COMPASS NO SUCH THING AS A
FILTER ANYWAY.
DAN BONGINO WAS WITH US.
AND COHOST OF THE HIT SHOW THE
FIVE GERALDO RIVERA.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS NO FILTER
TO GERALDO AS WELL.
I'M IN FOR THE QUESTION THAT YOU
WOULD YOU THINK JOE BIDEN AND
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS --
TELL ME WHAT THEY'VE DONE AND
WHAT POLICIES ARE WORKING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
I'D LOVE TO HEAR IT.
>> FIRST OF ALL I WAS BROUGHT UP
TO RESPECT MY ELDERS AND
JOE BIDEN AND I AND ARE THE SAME
AGE SOME VERY DEFENSIVE OF HIM
PERHAPS MORE SO.
>> Sean: LET ME STEP IN FOR
YOUR DEFENSE THERE GERALDO.
DAN WILL BACK ME UP I PROMISE
YOU YOU ARE SHARP, YOUR BRIGHT,
YOU ARTICULATE, YOU ARE ENGAGED
IN WHAT YOU ARE NO JOE BIDEN.
DAN I'M SURE YOU AGREE.
>> YEAH, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
[LAUGHS]
I WILL LET GERALDO TAKE IT FROM
HERE, BUT YOU'RE NOT MAKING THE
POINT I THINK YOU'RE MAKING
GERALDO GO AHEAD.
[LAUGHS]
>> I SUBMIT DAMP THAT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN YOU SEE DEEMS DAZED
AND CONFUSED [LAUGHS]
YOUR HALF MY AGE.
I FEEL BADLY, I FEEL BADLY FOR
JOE BIDEN.
IT'S OBVIOUS AS A STAFF FAILURE
ALL AROUND.
IF SOMEONE SAID REMINDED HIM.
>> Sean: HOLD ON A MINUTE.
THIS IS GOING TO DO THIS FROM
OUT ONE THING.
I FEEL BAD FOR THE COUNTRY.
I FEEL BAD FOR THE POOR, MIDDLE
CLASS, PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOMES
THAT ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE OF
HIS FAILED POLICIES.
I PUT THEM ABOVE ONE PERSON.
>> SURE WE DO SEAN, BUT THIS IS
THE CASE WHERE THE WHITE HOUSE
SHOULD'VE VERY EASILY SAID HE
MISSPOKE, HE APOLOGIZES, HE'S
CALLED THE FAMILY REGRET.
WHEN I WRITE ABOUT IT OR TALK
ABOUT ANYBODY I CHECK ON
WIKIPEDIA WHETHER THERE ALIVE OR
DEAD.
I MEAN MY STAFFERS SHOULD'VE
DONE THAT, HIS SHOULD'VE DONE
THAT.
THEY SHOULD BE CLEARED ON THE
TELEPROMPTER AND SO FORTH.
JUDGING BY THE POLICIES.
IT WAS NICE OF THEM TO HAVE THIS
PROGRAM TO END WORLD HUNGER THAT
SHOULD BE WAR TALK ABOUT
PARTICULARLY WITH THIS HORRIBLE
MESS IN FLORIDA.
SO MAYBE WE'LL SUFFERING.
WE NEED A PRESIDENT THAT IS
COMPASSIONATE.
WE HAVE GOT HER DOWN WHO IS
COMPASSIONATE AND EFFECTIVE
DeSANTIS, THEY ARE WORKING IN
A BIPARTISAN WAY.
I'M NOT SURE IT'S THE DAY WE
SING ALOUD THE GUY.
WE COULD'VE VERY EASILY WHEN
DIRECTED BY STAFFER.
>> Sean: DAN?
>> NUMBER ONE ON THE DAZED AND
CONFUSED THING, MY BROTHER YOU
ARE A STUDIO 54 GUY BACK IN THE
DAY SO I'M IN AND TAKE A HARD
PASS ON DAZED AND CONFUSED.
GERALDO, THEY ARE PROBABLY
DECADES OF YOUR LIFE YOU DON'T
EVEN REMEMBER.
[LAUGHS]
WE COULD TALK ABOUT THAT ALL
DAY.
WE CAN ANOTHER TIME.
MAYBE ON A RADIO SHOW OR
SOMETHING, BUT HAVING SAID THAT.
YOU ARE READING MISSING ENTIRELY
WRONG OKAY?
RESPECT FOR YOUR ELDERS AND
RESPECT FOR THE POWER OF THE
OBVERSE OF THE PRESIDENCY ARE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
I RESPECT MY ELDERS ARE NOT MAD
AT JOE BIDEN BECAUSE HE'S
CLEARLY SUFFERING SOME KIND OF
FRONTAL LOBE DEFICIT THAT A LOT
OF SENIOR AMERICANS AT THAT AGE
MAY BE ME TO AT THAT AGE, THEY
WILL SUFFER.
IT IS A SERIOUS THING.
I WENT TO GRADUATE SCHOOL FOR
NEUROPSYCHOLOGY AND VERY SERIOUS
ABOUT THE STUFF.
IT'S NOT A JOKE, IT'S NOT FUNNY.
HAVING SAID THAT THE MAN IS THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF OF THE MOST
POWERFUL MILITARY MACHINE IN THE
HISTORY OF PLANET EARTH.
HE COULD YOU LITERALLY
ANNIHILATE THE PLANET TOMORROW
MORNING.
IT IS NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK TO
HAVE THE GUY KNOW WHO'S ALIVE
AND DEAD IN A ROOM ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE VERY PROMINENT
CONGRESSWOMAN WHO WAS INVOLVED
IN JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING AND
CONGRESS KNOWS ABOUT.
HIS POINT NUMBER TWO THAT YOU'RE
MISSING TOO.
I'VE LITTLE BIT OF EXPERIENCE IN
THE SPACE, THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED SPACE EVERY SINGLE
FOOTSTEPS HE SAYS IS MARKED OUT.
EVERYTHING'S GONNA DO IS PUT
DOWN IS BRIEFED ON.
YOU WILL DO THIS, YOU WILL WORK
LEFT TO RIGHT.
YOU WILL EDUCATE EGGS EXCEED
LESS TRADE YOU WILL TAKE SIX
PHOTOS, TOO FAR PHOTOS
AFTERWARDS.
ANYTHING HE DOES IS LINED OUT.
HOW THE HELL BUT IS THIS GUY
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT TO DO AFTER
AN EVENT?
I'LL TELL YOU YOU DON'T SEE THIS
WHEN ANY OTHER PRESIDENT.
NOT TO THE DEGREE WITH THE SKY.
WHY IS THAT?
OF THAN A HUNDRED OF THESE
EVENTS IF NOT MORE.
BECAUSE THEY BRIEFED HIM ON WHAT
TO DO.
HE IS CLEARLY COGNITIVELY THERE
AND HE FORGETS.
GERALDO AT SOME WORK OBLIGATED
IN THAT.
>> ABOUT THE EMMYS?
WHAT ABOUT THE EMMYS, THE
ACADEMY AWARDS PERSON WHEN MAX
THE STATUETTE AND THEY DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO GO.
IT'S A NEW SETTING.
A NEW KIND OF PHYSICAL SPACE.
>> THE ARE NOT SETTING OFF
NUCLEAR EXPLOSIONS AT THE
ACADEMY AWARDS.
ARE YOU SERIOUS IN PUTTING THESE
TWO PEOPLE ON PAR, COME ON MAN.
WE NEED TO BE SERIOUS RIGHT NOW.
YOU TELL ME BRAD PITT AND
JOE BIDEN HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
IMPORTANCE?
BRAD PITT WAS THE GUY IN THAT
CHRISTIAN SLATER MOVIE WHO IS
DAZED AND CONFUSED ON THE COUCH
WASN'T IT?
IT'S NOT THE SAME JOB MAN.
I MEAN COME ON, THE GUYS TO
COMMANDER IN CHIEF THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY.
HER TELLING HIM EXIT STAGE
RIGHT, SHAKE HANDS WITH THIS GUY
AND LEAVE AND HE FORGETS
5 MINUTES LATER?
GERALDO, ONE MORE THING I DON'T
MONOPOLIZE A SEGMENT WERE NOT
THE ONLY ONES WATCHING THIS.
KIM JONG UN, AND VLADIMIR PUTIN
ARE WATCHING THIS TOO.
THE COOLIE KNOW THAT THE MAN
SOME FLANNEL LOBE DAMAGE.
>> DAN, ASK VLADIMIR PUTIN
WHETHER OR NOT JOE BIDEN IS
FORMIDABLE.
ASK HIM ABOUT HOW U.S.
INTELLIGENCE TOTALLY BLEW THE
WHISTLE ON VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE AND HAVE
BACKED.
>> Sean: LET ME GET THIS BACK
ON TRACK.
GERALDO, DO YOU BELIEVE EVERYONE
AROUND JOE BIDEN SEES WHAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT?
DO THEY SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING TO
THIS GUY?
YES OR NO?
ARE THEY AWARE OF IT?
PROBABLY WHERE MORE THAN WE
KNOW?
>> SOME PEOPLE GROW.
>> Sean: THE COGNITIVE MESS.
GERALDO, IF I SAW YOU ON TV AND
THIS WAS YOU ON A REGULAR BASIS.
I WOULD FLY TO WHERE YOU ARE, I
WOULD SIT DOWN WITH YOU AND I'D
SAY YOU'VE HAD AN INCREDIBLE 50
YEAR CAREER, PLEASE, PLEASE IT'S
TIME TO RETIRE.
BUT YOU NOT THAT WAY.
>> 52.
>> THE NEGLECT --
>> LISTEN.
>> LISTEN, I'M SORRY.
GET A FREAKING DOG BOW.
DOES THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU WANT A DOG, GET IT TO LICK
YOUR FEET MY DOG IS GREAT.
SHE WHEN I COME IN THE HOUSE SHE
GETS SO EXCITED.
I WANT THE PRESIDENT DOING THAT
TOO.
YOU CAN BE KIND AND YOUR POINT
BEFORE ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN
THINGS THAT JOE BIDEN'S A TOUGH
GUY?
HE WAITED FOR DONALD TRUMP TO
LEAVE OFFICE BEFORE HE INVADED
UKRAINE WHAT HE THOUGHT ABOUT?
>> HE INVADED UKRAINE AND AS A
RESULT RUSSIA IS GOING DOWN THE
PRIMROSE PATH.
MOST TO THE CHAGRIN OF MOST
PEOPLE.
>> NOT AFTER KILLING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF UKRAINIANS.
>> HE HAS DONE THE RIGHT THING.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT LET'S GIVE
DAN THE LAST WORD TONIGHT WILL
START WITH YOU GERALDO.
>> I JUST KNOW YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, HE CLEARLY IS NOT
RESPECTED BY WORLD LEADERS.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE
HE WAS NO SERIOUS THREAT TO
CROSS THE STREET.
THAT'S HAPPENING EVERY DAY NOW.
KIM JONG UN IS THREATENING HIS
SEVENTH NUCLEAR TEST AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS ANNEXING
PORTIONS OF UKRAINE.
I'VE NO IDEA WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BUT I RESPECT THIS GUY.
YOU'RE LAUGHING AT THEM I WISH
THEY WEREN'T ON A U.S. CITIZEN
IN PANAMA COUNTRY.
LET'S NOT BE SILLY HERE.
NOBODY RESPECTS THE SKY.
>> Sean: DAN GREAT TO SEE YOU,
AND BY THE WAY I ONE OF THE NAME
GERALDO.
BERNIE SANDERS IS AS SHARP AS A
TACK HE'S OLDER THAN JOE BIDEN.
HE DOESN'T SKIP A BEAT.
>> YEAH, HE'S GOT THREE HOUSES.
>> Sean: WHERE